♪
>> WE’VE ALWAYS SAID THAT IF AN
ELDER OR SENIOR IS IN LINE,
WE’RE GOING TO MOVE THEM TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE.
BARRING THAT, ANYONE WHO SIGNS
UP WHETHER YOU WORK IN ALASKA
AND IF YOU PLAN ON WORKING IN
ALASKA, YOU CAN GET A
VACCINATION.
WE’RE URGING AS MANY FOLKS AS
POSSIBLE TO DO THIS.
WE BELIEVE, NEIL, WE’RE GOING TO
BE ACHIEVING HERD IMMUNITY
PROBABLY BEFORE ANY OTHER STATE.
NEIL: BY FAR THE BIGGEST STATE
IN THE COUNTRY, NOW ALASKA
STANDS OUT FOR HAVING THE MOST
OPEN VACCINE POLICY OF ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN BE AS YOUNG WITH AS 16,
AND THEY’RE READY TO BOOGIE WHEN
IT COMES TO GIVING YOU THE
VACCINES.
MIKE DUN LEVY RAISED THE POINT
WHERE THE RANGING WAIT TIMES
WITH PEOPLE WHO JUST WANT TO GET
THAT VACCINE SEEMED A LITTLE BIT
SILLY.
MIKE PARSONS, THE GOVERNOR OF
MISSOURI, IS DEALING WITH THESE
ISSUES OF THE VACCINES AND
GETTING EVERYONE WHAT THEY NEED
WHEN THEY NEED IT.
HE’S KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN US ON A
SATURDAY FROM SPRINGFIELD.
GOVERNOR, VERY GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN.
HOW YOU DOING?
>> I’M DOING GOOD, NEIL.
GOOD TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
NEIL: SAME HERE.
LET’S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT YOUR VACCINE KIND OF RULES
ARE.
WHO GETS TO THE FRONT OF THE
LINE, HOW BIG IS THAT LINE?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW, THE MAIN PRIORITY
WE’VE HAD IS THE SAME PLAN WE
SET IN OCTOBER, THE CDC, AND WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY EXECUTING THAT
PLAN JUST LIKE IT WAS ORIGINALLY
PUT TOGETHER AND MAKING SURE
WE’RE NOT DOING KNEE-JERK
REACTIONS TO EVERYBODY WANTING
TO JUMP THE LINE.
OUR BIGGEST PRIORITY IS PEOPLE
65 YEARS AND OLDER, THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION IN OUR
STATE, AND WE STAYED FOCUSED ON
THAT.
NEXT WEEK WE’LL GO TO THE NEXT
LEVEL, BUT THAT’S, FRANKLY,
SEVERAL WEEKS AHEAD OF IT.
AND RIGHT NOW WE’RE SECOND IN
THE UNITED STATES WITH THE
LOWEST POSITIVITY RATE IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE THAT GOING
BECAUSE OF THINGS WE’VE DONE,
AND WE NEVER SHUT OUR STATE
DOWN, WE NEVER SHUT DOWN THE
STATE OF MISSOURI.
WE NEVER DID THE MANDATES FROM
THE GOVERNOR’S OFFICE.
SO I THINK A COMBINATION OF
STAYING WITH THE VACCINE PLAN
AND MAKING SURE WE GET THAT DONE
AND HAVING THE NATIONAL GUARD --
I CAN’T SAY ENOUGH FOR THEIR
SUPPORT -- DOING MASS VACCINE
OPERATIONS.
AND WE WILL BE DOING A
MEGA-VACCINE OPERATION NEXT WEEK
IN KANSAS CITY, MISSOURI.
SO THERE’S NOT ENOUGH VACCINE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
EVERYBODY DOES.
BUT, I MEAN, IT’S ALL HANDS ON
DECK RIGHT NOW, AND WE’RE PUDDLE
NEEDLES IN PEOPLE’S -- PUTTING
NEEDLES IN PEOPLE’S ARMS THAT
WANT IT.
NEIL: THE PRIME MINISTER HAS A
GOAL OF -- THE PRESIDENT HAS A
GOAL OF GETTING EVERYONE THAT
WANTS TO BE VACCINATED BY MAY
1ST.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK WE’LL GET
CLOSE TO THAT.
I DON’T KNOW THAT YOU’RE GOING
TO GET IT ALL DONE BY MAY THE
1ST.
I THINK THAT’S A PREDICTION,
WISHFUL THINKING, IT’S GOING TO
TAKE US A WHILE TO GET EVERYBODY
VACCINATE LDED.
I THINK THE MAIN THING IS YOU
GET THE HIGH RISK CATEGORIES
DONE.
I DO THINK WE CAN GET THAT DONE
BY THE FIRST PART OF MAY, AND I
THINK YOU’RE GOING TO SEE IN THE
NEXT 60 DAYS WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO
TO PHARMACY, THE HEALTH CARE
CLINICS AND PROBABLY GET
VACCINES ON ON THEIR OWN THAN
HAVING TO DEPEND ON STATE
GOVERNMENTS TO RUN THOSE PLANS.
NEIL: GOVERNOR, WHAT IS YOUR
POLICY ON MASKS?
>> I’M SORRY, NEIL, WHAT WAS
THAT?
NEIL: I’M SORRY.
WHAT’S YOUR POLICY ON MASKS,
GOVERNOR?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE NEXT
THING WE’RE GOING TO BE DOING AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IS TO GO TO SOME
OF THE MEGA VACCINES AND THEN
ALSO WE’LL TAKE THAT NEXT STAGE
OF PEOPLE THAT COMES IN, AND
WE’LL BE IN WHAT WE CALL PHASE
THREE.
AND PHASE THREE WE’LL GET PRETTY
CLOSE TO THE ENTIRE GENERAL
PUBLIC THAT’S OUT THERE.
SO, AGAIN, WE’RE ABOUT TWO WEEKS
AHEAD OF EVERYTHING WE’VE
PREDICTED SO FAR AT THIS POINT.
SO WE JUST KEEP MOVING THAT TO
THE NEXT LEVEL.
NEIL: GOVERNOR, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
VERY LITTLE FANFARE.
YOU’VE JUST BEEN VERY DILIGENT
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS, AND IT
SEEM TO BE WORKING.
MIKE PARSON, GOVERNOR OF THE